les Chéries une miniérie appelé hackur
stories sur My canal est disponible
retrace les histoires les plus
captivantes des plus grands hackurs et
cybercriminels de notre génération je
sais que vous adorez ça moi aussi
j'adore ça pour ça que je me suis
intéressé à toutes ces histoires ces
histoires elles sont racontées par
plusieurs intervenants et Rabin des bois
que l'on connaî bien notamment regardez
la bande annonce regardez vous allez
voir des histoires de fou ça je pense
que vous allez adorer
[Musique]
regardez
c'est quelque chose qui a marqué
l'histoire de l'Internet complètement
c'est la plus grosse arnaque au
cryptomonnaie jamais réalisé on est
clairement dans du Pablo Escobar 2.0 à
ce
niveau je m'appelle Rav des bois je suis
haur et écrivain et aujourd'hui je vais
vous raconter les histoires les plus
fascinantes des plus grands
cyberciminels de notre
[Musique]
époquereous des bois expert en
cyberciminalité alors il il y a plein
d'histoires il y a par exemple
l'histoire de pupi h PUP ouais h PUP
c'est un escroc nigérien qui
actuellement fait 11 ans de prison ferme
aux États-Unis c'est un mec qui a volé
plus de 100 millions de dollars à la
base ce qu'il fait c'est des arnaques
donc ce qu'on appelle du business email
compromise admettons cy que vous ayez
une entreprise je sais pas anuna
Corporation et que vous devez payer des
gens HP en fait c'est un mec qui va
aller hacker des comptables et des
secrétaires uniquement dans des
entreprises qui va un petit peu prendre
le temps de regarder comment ça
fonctionne ventre entreprise les
factures qu'il y a à payer s'il y a
aussi des paiements qui sont récurrents
et en gros hpier au bout d'un moment il
va changer les informations bancaires
donc le RIB par les siennes donc au lieu
de payer ce que vous pensez être un
client normal en fait vous allez envoyer
de l'argent à H papi on estime qu'il a
fait plus de 100 millions de dollars de
dégâts il s'est fait arrêter à Dubaï par
une opération conjointe entre le FBI et
la police de Dubaï ils l'ont retrouvé
avec 40 millions en cash 13 voitures de
luxe c'est sans doute l'un des plus
grand cybercriminel de notre génération
ou tout du moins des 10 dernières années
je l'appelle le prince du cybercrime et
c'est l'épisode 1 de hacker stories
exactement c'est l'épisode 1 C pou
retrouver sur My canal depuis hier vous
revenez aussi sur Rouja ignatova ouais
Ruja ignatova c'est tout simplement la
femme la plus recherchée au monde c'est
la seule femme qui est dans la liste des
top 10 Most Wanted par le FBI donc en
fait il y a pas une meuf plus recherchée
sur la planète que elle ah ouais elle a
volé dans son arnaque au Ponzi 4
milliards de dollars donc elle a arnaqué
3 millions de personnes elle a fait une
criryptomonnaie s appelle one coin qui
est en fait une fausse cryptoomonnaie
dans laquelle il y a absolument rien
dedans les gens ont investi de malade et
tu gagnais des bonus si jamais tuas
invitais des frérot dans dans le truc en
fait donc si moi je propose à jeanm
d'investir dans onecoin je vais recevoir
un bonus donc en fait je le tue en en
voulant lui proposer une opportunité il
y a eu 4 milliards de de dollars de
dégâts et elle elle a disparu de la
surface de la planète en prenant un
avion un jour elle avait une conférence
au Portugal elle monte dans un vol et
plus personne ne l'a jamais revu à
partir de ce jour-là c'est toujours la
femme la plus recherchée au monde fort
fort là ces histoires es sont incroyes
c'est incroyable il y a l'histoire aussi
des bony and clly de la cyber atttaque
he euh ouais alors eux c'est razelkan et
Ilia Lichtenstein ce sont en gros ils
ont hacké une plateforme de cryptonnaie
qui s'appelait bitfex en 2017 à l'époque
ça valait 70 millions ils ont volé
120000 Bitcoin sauf qu'en fait avec le
temps le Bitcoin a exploser en terme de
prix et ils sont retrouvés sur un magot
de 4,5 milliards de dollars et en fait
ils ont essayé de blanchir cet argent de
disparaître d'aller notamment en Ukraine
mais ils sont fait rattraper par la
police il y a un film en préparation sur
sur Netflix avec anata c'est une hisire
de fou aussi et c'est l'épisode 5 de la
série c'est fort alors c'est quoi les
arnaques les plus répandu en fait les
arnaques les plus répandu c'est le
fishing peut-être que vous recevez
souvent des des SMS comme ça ça peut
être des trucs tout cons par exemple
vous avez une commande colissimo qui
arriveent
énormémentnormément Fa no bah voilà bah
du coup concrètement c'est c'est des
gens qui ils savent en fait que vous
avez passé une commande et que vous
attendez de la livraison donc souvent ça
va vous demander un petit frais de
familial de genre 1 € 2 € pour pouvoir
accéder à votre livraison comme quoi il
y a des taxes ça bien sûr c'est une
arnaque sauf qu'en fait si tu envois ça
à 1 million de Français et que tu as
neque 1 % de personnes qui cliquent tu
fais de l'oseille donc ça c'est
extrêmement fréquent sinon il y a les
arnaques à la Love romance donc ça c'est
faire te faire en gros dire que tu es
amoureux de toi que tu as besoin
d'argent tout ça développer des
sentiments ce qu'on appelle de
l'ingénierie sociale les breurs les BR
aussi notamment h papier est un broueur
et c'est le c'est concrètement un ravage
c'est ce qu'on appelle de l'ingénierie
sociale et c'est utiliser les émotions
pour manipuler les gens alors pour nos
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent à
19h56 on est en direct c'est quoi les
les les arnaques voilà qu'il vont avoir
à part ça sur lesquel il faut qu'il se
méfie au niveau des mails au niveau des
SMS moi je pense qu'avec lia il va se
passer des dingueries intergalactiques
je pense notamment que le Jeep fake donc
c'est en fait quand on reprend la voix
de quelqu'un ou quand on reprend l'image
et la vidéo de quelqu'un moi par exemple
demain je pourrais très bien appeler
Janie en me faisant passer pour Cyril tu
entendrais la voix de Cyril peut-être
même que si on fait un FaceTime tu
verrais le visage de Cyril et je te dis
j'anis frérot j'ai besoin d'oseille
envoie-moi 1000 balles oui c'est c'est
pas le scénario plus crédible non
plus ça sera peut-être pas dans ce sens
déccher pas ça va rien dire ça je dire
quand tu dévises tu dévisses et
concrètement pour te répondre cyil c'est
l'usurpation d'identité je pense que
c'est ça le futur du cyber c'est les
gens qui vont utiliser votre identité
pour se faire passer pour vous et
après tu as raison parce que maintenant
on peut prendre le visage on on le fait
ici hein avec la même voix tuappelle
j'appelle Gil verd dis vas-y tu sais
quoi voilà est-ce que Fatou est là et là
voilà ça part en cacahuète quoi je vous
répond ouais imagine si demain imaginez
simplement si demain je me fais passer
pour l'un de vos enfants que je pense sa
voixouage
ite jeis
pas énormément de personnes qui vont se
faire avoir comme ça je pense et c'est
important ce genre de contenu pour
sensibiliser pour sensibiliser les gens
avec une conscience numérique on une
question BFM la question BFM du jour et
le sing aussi la personne qui prend le
contrôle de sa carte téléphone c'est
hyper tendance en ce moment la personne
tout vos comptes bancaires parce qu'il y
a tout de sur votre téléphone euh moi
j'ai mon passeport qui est swpping alors
ça c'est
unage ça cartonne en ce moment pardon
ouais ouais ça cartonne malheureusement
à cause prend le contrôle de la carte
SIM on accède à ses comptes bancaires à
tout parce qu'on a tout dans notre
téléphone en fait on appelle l'opérateur
téléphonique big orange fre pour les
cités et concrètement on se fait passer
pour quelqu'un de de la famille on dit
qu'on a besoin de réinitialiser le mot
de passe rapidement ou alors qu'on a
changé de de carte on a on a perdu sa
carte SIM et qui faire il faut faire une
portabilité numéro et en fait ce sont
des hackeurs qui manipulent le service
client d'opérateur téléphonique dans le
but de gagner accès à votre numéro de
téléphone et comme malheureusement
aujourd'hui on associe trop de choses à
notre numéro de téléphone derrière ils
peuvent récupérer l'accès à vos comptes
bancaires ils peuvent récupérer l'accès
à vos réseaux sociaux donc ça par contre
malheureusement pour la question BFM je
pense que c'est plutôt du côté des
opérateurs téléphoniques de former leurs
employés parce que c'est eux qui sont
avoir ça veut dire que vous n conseillez
pas d'avoir les applications par exemple
de notre de notre banque ou sur vre
téléphone je vous conseille d'avoir ce
qu'on appelle l'authentification à deux
facteurs code qu'on reçoit pas par SMS
c'est uniquement sur une application ou
alors une clé que vous planquez que vous
vous mettez directement dans votre
téléphone comme ça votre numéro de
téléphone n'est pas associé avec tout ça
et même si si je sais pas demain vous
vous changez de numéro vous avez
totalement oublié bah vous allez vous
retrouver comment dire en difficulté en
fait avec le compte bancaire le numéro
parce que moi je compte compte bancaire
pas forcément c'estàdire que si demain
j'ai ton numéro de téléphone ouais après
moi derrière je vais pouvoir me
connecter à partir de ton numéro de
téléphone et tu sais quand tu fais des
mot de passes oubliés ça va te l'envoyer
directement sur ton téléphone ou alors
sur ton adresse email et bien souvent
les gens sécurisent leur adresse email
avec leur numéro de téléphone donc le
Sim spping ça fait un ravage aux
États-Unis je crois que ça a causé plus
de 40 millions de dégâts cette année
c'est et quand on va chez l'opérateur
juste avec le nom et l'adresse il vous
reduplique la carte SIM voilà voilà mais
aprs comme ça tu récupère après toutes
les données qu'on a dans son téléphone
faut former les employés des opérateurs
pour que ça n il y a beaucoup de hackurs
en ce moment et je crois que Paul Sky en
était victime qui font sauter les
comptes Instagram snapchat TikTok
comment vous faites est-ce que c'est
aussi facile de faire sauter un
compte je vais pas je vais pas trahir de
secrets mais disons que si jamais il y a
suffisamment de personnes qui reportent
en masse votre compte est-ce que vous
seul vous pouvez faire sauter un compte
par exemple il se pourrait ou parce
qu'il va faire des comp pour
àel tu peux faire du chantage ou alors
carrément il y a des gens qui payent
pour que tu fasses sauter les compes
d'autres personnes auss a jalousie voilà
ou ouais c'est les banquiers aussi
appellent enfin c'est pas les banquiers
du coup et ils vous disent voilà c'est
Monsieur Dupont de votre banque j'ai vu
qu'il y avait un problème sur votre
compte il y a des sortes de de mouvement
un peu bizarres est-ce que vous pouvez
éventuellement valider l'opération que
je vais vous donner ça c'est le nouveau
truc qui vient de sortir alors ouais ça
c'est extrêmement fréquent aussi parce
qu'en fait ce sont des gens qui
récupèrent vos informations bancaires
mais quand vous faites une transaction
de nos jours maintenant 2023 vous allez
avoir un code de vérification et sens ce
code vous pouvez pas en fait tout
simplement acheter la chose donc le
l'arnaqueur va lui faire un achat en
cours admettons un iPhone n'importe quoi
et il va il va recevoir une demande de
code et il va se faire passer pour votre
banquier en vous disant madame ma vous
êtes en train de vous faire hacker vite
envoyez-moi le code à chif mais en fait
c'est lui qui est en train de vous
hacker c'est courant aussi en ce moment
très courant très très courant est-ce
que vous a déjà demandé de faire un truc
de ouf contre une grosse somme d'argent
que vous avez refusé par éthique
ouais peut-être que j'ai même pas refusé
peut-être que je l'ai fait bien sûr
c'est un c'est un milieu qui est
extrêmement lucratif faut partir du
principe que le crime il est en train
d'évoluer il passe de la rue au clavier
combien ça gagne un cœur ça gagne très
bien sa vie ça gagne très très bien sa
vie c'est minimum 5 chiffres par mois tu
peux monter à après ça dépend si tu es
dans le comment dire si tu es dans le
légal illégal et tout moi par exemple
j'ai arrêté tout ce qui était illégal
j'ai à question SP Paris en 2018 après
mêre faire recaler et j'ai arrêté
totalement le cybercrime mais
aujourd'hui juste en faisant du du du
consulting en cybersécurité je m'en sors
quand même très très bien en fait parce
que c'est quelque chose qui touche tout
le monde et ça va continuer à toucher
tout le monde bien sûr oui et sans
donner leur identité est-ce que vous
connaissez les hackeurs dont on parle
qui rentrent par exemple dans les
systèmes de sécurité français anglais
dans les trucs militaires pour faire du
chantage chez che les entreprises pareil
pour faire du chantage les hpitaux
récemment HPUX Hux vous avez des
collègues qui font ça collègues entre
guillets moi moi je suis plus du tout
sur la scène criminel en ce disons que
je suis passé du côté lumière de la
force et que j'ai arrêté toute toutes
les singeries mais je connais je connais
oui je connais certains repenti on déjà
fait des des très grosses choses je
pense notamment à matthie swish qui est
un intervenant qui qui a débusquer un
virus qui touchit l'intégralité de la
planète on a mais moi je fréquente plus
trop
voilà on avait pas été hacké nous à un
moment donné enfin nous sur le compte
Twitter sur sur les sondagesou il y
avait des ils avaient boosté les sondage
je me souviens c'est ultra facile mais
ça c'est ultra facile mais ça c'était
juste parce que c'était des mecs qui
voulaient booster Gill
verd mais c'est ultcile ça ouais ça
c'est ultra facile il suffit d'avoir une
armée de compte Twitter et après tout
simplement il y a son d' htpmp et tu
fais en sorte que tous les tous les
botes tous les comptes ils votent oui ou
il votent non et du coup tu manipules
totalement l'opinion publique puisque si
tu penses que la majorité pense d'une
façon et que c'est pas vrai
h comment dire raisonn des g la la la la
police euh et la justice est-ce qu'on
ont encore trop peu de moyens face à ça
dépend en France on a une très très
belle institution qui s'appelle LAN
c'est les cyber pompiers c'est pas les
cyberflic c'est quand il y a une merde
quand il y a un hack eux ils viennent
ils éteignent le ha ils sont très très
forts après nos services de
renseignement la DGSI et la DGSE sont
aussi très très forts je pense que ce
qui manque véritablement c'est pas
forcément du point de vue policier mais
plus citoyen je pense qu'il manque une
conscience numérique faut que les gens
se forment faut qu'il réalisent que si
tu passes 5 heur par jour devant un
écran mais que tu te rends pas compte
des conséquences que ça peut engendrer
c'est là où c'est grave en fait quand tu
utilises un truc et que tu le comprends
pas ça oui c'est ma question est-ce que
vous allez plus vite que la police
aujourd'hui parce que quand on va pour
une je sais pas des menaces qu'on reçoit
des numéros inconnus la police souvent a
du mal à retracer ça est-ce que vous
vous faites facilement plus facilement
ça dépend quoi ça dépend quoi on peut
j'aiir un numéro masqué est-ce que vous
pouvez le traquer facilement non numéro
masqué beaucoup plus compliqué mais par
contre après si c'est des des réseaux
sociaux oui ça s'appelle de l'obsec donc
la sécurité opérationnelle c'est être
sûr qu'en fait tu sois protégé sur
Internet et personne ne puisse te
retrouver si tu as une bonne obsèque
personne va te retrouver si tu as une
mauvaise obsèque en trois clics on
connait ton nom ton prénom ton adresse
et ton numéro de téléphone oui pour les
pour les gens qui qui regardent si on
avait un conseil à leur donner par
rapport au mot de passe notamment il
faut pas qu'on ait le même mot de passe
pour tous nos exactement ça c'est un
très bon conseil d'hygiène numérique
c'est d'avoir différents mot de passes à
chaque fois sur chaque plateforme parce
mais alors d' où est-ce qu'on les
retient estce que si on a 15 mot de
passes comment tu peux utiliser un
gestionnaire de mot de passe
malheureusement la plupart sont payants
après tu peux faire des variantes dans
ta tête avec des ch diff diff en fait
uneme fait et que tonot de passe je sais
pas c'est vast 4 et ben en
fait
[Rires]
grosés utilise sur un site ce site là se
fait hacker bah après on sait que ton
mot de pass c'est Anouna 456 on va
réessayer de hacker ton compte sur
d'autres plateformes et il vont essayer
Facebook Instagram tout ça tout ça tout
ça comment tu as pu sortir vastoné je
sais pasère j'ai une inspie la vérité
j'ai j'ai une inspie de
malade c'était préparé ou pas non qu
c'était préparé ou improvisé même pas
que tutais en regardant tu as dit vast
tener comme ça je cherchais un mot de
pass j'étais en inspiration en crétivité
et donc pas associer son téléphone à son
adresse email jamais ex mon alors pour
vous juste pour donner un un petit tuto
de ce que tu pourrais faire mon numéro
de téléphone il est même pas associé à
mon véritable nom et prénom et après
derrière toutes mes applications il y en
a aucune qui est relié à mon téléphone
quand bien même quelqu'un arriverait à
prendre le contrôle de mon numéro de
téléphone il aura ni mon nom ni mon
prénom et il pourra pas accéder derrière
à mes applications que j'utilise tous
les jours ah ouais mais comment c'est
possible ça de dissocier les
applications de de son téléphone par
exemple sur Twitter Instagram Facebook
tu es pas obligé de mettre ton numéro de
téléphone tu peux mettre ton adresse
email un une une application
d'authentification tu es pas obligé de
mettre ton numéro de téléphone mais de
toute façon on est on est vulnérable
parce que là par exemple c'est la
période des fêtes la plupart du temps
quand on va quand on va commander
quelque chose ou même quand on va faire
ses courses sur Internet on nous demande
et notre adresse et notre mail et notre
numéro de téléphone pour les livreurs
donc on est ah moi jamais en fait il
faut il y a du bon et il y a du mauvais
si tu es par exemple sur Amazon de
fité ouais zé4 de fidélité c'est
dingue c'est ça le niveau de
je su
prudente mais incroyable euh frérot
est-ce que tu peux donner euh vraiment
trois conseils importants pour nos
téléspectateurs à 20h6 qu'ils ont très
peur de tout ça faire arnaquer non mais
parce qu'on reçoit souvent des SMS
chelous ouais répond pas moiattends moi
je réponds même pas au SMS normaux tu
CIS je répondre au SMS chelou non mais
c'est vrai tu l'as vu ou pas même pas je
répond moime les liens des amendes comme
çai il y a des mecs il y a même des mecs
Mo moi moi je crois beaucoup à la à la
chance il y a même des mecs qui portent
pour moi qui qui porte la poisse il
m'envoie des sms je supprime direct je
veux même pas lire surê je veux même pas
les l Mme pas quelun autour de la table
là qui porte la sinon vous seriez pas là
non non c'est vrai tous ceux qui sont là
c'était voilà oui des conseils qu'on
pourrait donner rapidement donc ne pas
réutiliser les mêmes mot de passe ça on
a dit ne pas utiliser des trop des
choses trop évidentes dans vos mot de
passe ne mettez pas le nom de vos
enfants la date de naissance quoi
d'autre on pourrait en fait un conseil
général faut se dire que tout ce que
vous publiez sur Internet tout ce que
vous postez et tout c'est à tout jamais
inscrit il y aura jamais personne qui va
pouvoir l'enlever donc faut éviter de
faire j'ai une question AV à la wifi
parce que moi un jour apparemment grâce
à la Wii il y a des gens qui ont
retrouvé mon adresse qui ont appelé la
police et qui ont dit qu'il y a un
meurtre chez moi et du coup la police
qui a débarqué ils ont mis ma mère par
terre et tout donc comment on protéger
par rapport à la wifi alors ça ça
s'appelle le swatching c'est extrêmement
courant aux États-Unis ça allit
heureusement un peu Mo en France
concrètement on trouve ton adresse IP ok
ton adresse IP c'est un petit peu comme
si c'était l'adresse de ta box Internet
et en trouvant ton adresse IP derrière
ils vont appeler les services de police
ils vont se faire passer pour je sais
pas moi un voisin ils vont dire oh mon
dieu venez vite j'entends paulska qui
est en train de se faire tirer dessus OK
ou j'entends Paska qui est en train de
hurler et donc du coup eux ce qu'ils
font ils sont obligés c'est la loi bah
ils viennent chez toi ils défoncent ta
porte sert à quoi de faire ça bah TR
genre c'est c'est c'est des gens très
mal inentionnés qui font ça quoi c'est
pour causer du mal et et voilà c'est
c'est une dérive d'Internet qui est
malheureusement très triste r Oui ma
mère elle avait la jambe cassée les
policiers l' mis par terre et tout parce
que moi j'ai appelé parce qu'on ma
prévenu j'ai dit non non c'est faux ils
ont dit bah on est obligé de venir
vérifier en fait
oui est-ce qu'on peut partir du principe
qu'il neous faut ouvrir aucun lien sur
Instagram sur Twitter partout nulle part
quand on on reçoit un truc avec une
adresse d'un lien regarde cette vidéo
même si c'est quelqu'un qu'on connaît on
sait pas trop est-ce qu'on part du
principe qu'on ouvre jamais les liens ça
va dépendre du lien en question et de de
l'URL si jamais tu vois un truc bizarre
avec trop de consonne que c'est pas
leasy pas prononciable que le mec tu lui
as pas parlé depuis mai 2001 et qui
t'envoie un SMS en mode frérot clic faut
se douter quoi en fait c'est du bon sens
c'est on nous dit que quand il y a
HTTPS s ça veut dire que c'est sécurisé
sécurisé mais en vrai c'est pas c'est
pas fa quand même derrière ça va r
changer